country faces a major crime wave one
liberal city solution is to go after and
punish
law-abiding gun owners san jose
california approving a plan that would
charge residents who legally own
firearms
for the cost of criminal gun violence it
includes an annual fee and would force
people to buy
liability insurance coverage and if
residents don't comply you're ready
they will confiscate your gun greg
you've looked into this
totally legal right absolutely i'm a
legal expert on guns and they could just
come and take mine
it'll be fun for everybody the idea of
calling it gun insurance
gun insurance is really clever because
your argument can be
like well there's car insurance why
can't there be gun insurance well it's
because
car insurance doesn't require you to
cover other people's accidents right
so this doesn't make any sense it's
absurd uh on its face
law-abiding gun owners by their
definition getting a gun
makes them you know they're not targets
for criminals
less target for criminals but then they
become targets for liberals
right but it's a fair trade-off it's
like no one
every day they come up with a stupid
idea and we have to talk about it
but it's not gonna happen remember all
the crime is caused by bad people
with stolen guns in cities where
politicians
uh put these thugs back on the street
before the next victim is done at their
shift in chinatown
so we know how to solve that tax we have
these task forces that take guns off the
street
you got to get that out there bring back
stop and frisk
lock up the thugs with guns problem
solved so many things wrong with this
harold just one of them that greg
touched on the part about
how you go about confiscating someone's
gun it's probably
not going to withstand that's the beta
o'rourke uh school of thought
the other reality is gun everyone's
entitled to own a gun on the second
amendment uh you're not entitled on a
car
so you don't have to have insurance with
which is why this thing is going to have
a problem
that was a better way of putting the
holes in this argument
you said that but i but i give them
credit for this i think the the
when we try to reset and imagine and
reimagine ways to deal with a challenge
and a problem that's what they're doing
this is not the way to do it i've said
before and i'll say it again the ghost
gun issue which the president's going
after is a huge huge part
because those stolen guns someone had to
have their gun stolen now if you buy a
hundred guns and all of a sudden all of
them are stolen
something might be fishy about what
you're doing and how these guns again
i've said it over and over again you
can't get a fresh apple
a good book a dental visit and a lot of
these neighborhoods where these people
are
these kids are finding guns we have to
keep trying and i give them credit for
trying but this is not going to
withstand a legal challenge well i've
been to the neighborhoods you're talking
about you can get apples harold
yeah you can definitely get apples but
inside the apples are guns
all right what about you digging this
does not ring true to you
inside the apple or ammo which is
extremely in
very short supply right now this is
left-wing performance art it's liberal
theater
coming from literally the richest city
in america
so their message is only wealthy people
and rich people are allowed to own guns
those people who can afford the
insurance
and the fees on the gun so this is
actually
jim crow you put the burden on
lower income individuals they can't
they're not allowed to defend themselves
lower income communities neighborhoods
high crime areas
communities of color that's what so
disgusting the reason is theater
is because these jackasses on the city
council clearly have
bigger political ambitions so what
they're going to do is have
all these gun rights groups pay for the
legal fees when they get their pants
sued off of them
over this law and then they're going to
use it for public relations but it's not
going anywhere
yeah it's a great point again i've made
none of them but
i'll summarize all of them you're not
supposed to you're leading the secretary
right thank god it
or please is on the middle class though
because the middle class is already
struggling with i don't know gas prices
all the other insurance they have to pay
for um
you're talking about sending your kids
to college that's not cheap and now
you're going to have to take out a
policy
another policy on guns no well it also
is
um the democrats say they want to talk
about root causes like
again this is not doing if you're trying
to go around the second amendment it
doesn't work so it's not going to hold
up in court
it is a waste of time and right nearby
in oakland california the city council
wants to take away 18 million dollars of
the police budget
and i'm not sure how that would you know
go over in northern california but
except for the police chief says
it's going to be very difficult for them
to be able to do any of their jobs
to respond to calls including gun crime
greg
if someone came to your house and asked
you if you had an insurance policy on
your firearm and you said no
and they said well you know we're going
to have to confiscate that weapon
what would you do you know i have to go
back to one of those great films
science of the lambs where i would
always ask the person to come inside
i'd say come on in can i make you some
tea and i would be incredibly
incredibly gracious and then they would
wake up days later
wondering where they are change in your
basement in my basement
okay because that's the fallacy of all
of these gun confiscation arguments is
that
who is going to be in charge of knocking
on doors and confiscating guns
not not a single government official is
going to raise their hand and say i want
to be
in that department not even the atf
would do that right this is why it's
garbage this whole thing is absolutely
just
hot garbage but it places the lotion in
the basket grain
yes it's absurd political gay manship
what was that yeah
have you seen that film it's rated r
dana i don't know are you glad to watch
that i don't even know what they're
talking about
i don't know either but no silence i
like the idea of like applying
insurance to areas where there is none
because that's kind of interesting like
could you have like children insurance
like if
your kids turn like if your kids do
something really bad
i could buy a policy on the twins yes so
that so that like let's say your kids do
something really stupid
you don't want to be responsible for
their stupidity you actually can get
that
really hard yeah if they're under if
they're under the age of 18 i think that
that would be your on broad liability
coverage that you have through your
homeowners insurance i don't
maybe don't know that but i may be
sounding great though can you get like
getting fired insurance
you can take out a policy on a child
that if they flame out
professionally it's like a workers comp
thing they're unable to function in
society and i think you can get them
paid 40 grand a year no taxes there you
go
how do i know that don't ask let's hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else